Let me introduce.
Okay. Um
Welcome to the DDPS seminar, everyone.
Before we introduce our invited speaker
today, let's go over some rules and
logistics. First of all, please mute
yourselves during the talk, but if you
have questions, you can unmute and ask
questions.
Or
or
use chat room to post your questions so
that we can address them in Q&A session
at the end. Uh second, today's DDPS
seminar is open to external audiences.
Therefore, no classified discussion is
allowed. Finally, the talk today will be
recorded
and uploaded in our YouTube channel.
That's about it. Now, let me briefly
introduce our speaker today.
Uh it is an honor to host Dr. uh Karthik
Murthy, who is a professor in the
Department of
at the University of Michigan.
He obtained his PhD PhD at Stanford
University in 1996.
Between 2016 and 2022, he served as the
director of the Michigan State Michigan
Institute uh for Computational Discovery
and Engineering.
His research is in computational science
with applications drawn from biophysics,
material physics, mechanics, and
um mathematical uh biology. Uh
mathematical biology. Uh of recent
interest are
of course data-driven approaches to
computational science.
Uh today, Krishna will present an
interesting topic, which is
Fokker-Planck inverse reinforcement
uh reinforcement uh learning. Uh I'm
sure we will hear an exciting talk
today. But before I pass the button to
Krishna, uh let me ask a couple of
questions
to Krishna just to get to know you
better and make this seminar so much
informal. Not nothing serious, okay?
Sure.
Don't worry. Um first question goes um
obviously um you're passionate about
computational science and
to the applications to biology and uh
the material science.
Uh is there any moment in your life when
you realized that wow, this is it. This
is the field I would like to commit my
career to this.
If you want to
share that.
So
So So I actually I do remember when I
think I was a postdoc when I decided
that you know, I I remember a particular
moment when I said yes, actually the the
materials physics work was really
interesting and I I remember that
happening.
Uh and that was during my postdoc time.
Um and then I came to Michigan and I
remember
some of my colleagues were already
working in
not quite biology, but really soft
tissue doing soft tissue mechanics and
so forth. And and you know, there are
many
things we we can do from computation
there. So this was early 2000s and I
remember telling them at that time that
yes, bio is very interesting, but I
think I have my plate full.
But then
I was looking at some problems in in
growth, just you know, just growth of uh
continuing growth, right? And the
application to biology is very obvious.
And then I realized that well, here I
have this. If I don't use it, I lose it.
So so you know, even though I thought I
my plate was too full, I started looking
at problems in biology. And that has
grown. I went into other problems of
when it is cell mechanics and I look at
looked at embryogenesis and things like
that.
Uh and then of course when the interest
or in in scientific machine learning
came up, uh it was very natural. I think
most computational people find this to
be a natural extension of the work we've
been doing on computation.
Uh so yes, I we continue to draw
applications from uh biophysics as well
as materials physics and um
but but it's very clear I'm um
yeah, in some in some cases I'm
considered a computational materials
physicist some people consider me a
computational biophysicist but I think
the computation comes first.
Mhm. I see I see.
Sorry long winded answer but hopefully
that's it.
No no very good very good.
Um I guess you you chose a wide field
to commit your career to. Um
Um I mean because of that I you know you
got many many awards during your career.
And one of them is Presidential Early
Career Award for Scientists and
Engineers.
That seems very special.
Would you mind sharing some story about
receiving that award and
Yeah actually that that that award has
it's it
it you know the the PK's as it's called
Yeah.
is is something that all the agencies
can put forward
nominees for across all agencies.
At that time it was
it was I actually there's there's a good
connection with with with with the labs
because I was
advanced as a as a nominee through the
through the DOE.
And so
I have colleagues and I've been working
with people
at Sandia for a long time Sandia
California which is just across the road
from you guys.
Mhm.
And and that that that was a nomination.
So yes so so it's it's it's pretty
special and that was
that was a long time ago.
And and that was for it was it was of
course early career and
that was when I was still just thinking
of some of the ideas
from a long time ago that step by step
brought me here. So um
Incremental.
Yeah incremental definitely.
Awesome awesome. Well thank you thank
you so much.
Thanks thanks thanks for the question
that's that's nice.
And we are
looking forward to your
exciting talk. Great floor is yours.
Thank you thank you so much Ansook.
Well good morning well I shouldn't say I
don't people are joining from all over,
so whatever. Good day to everybody
wherever you are and all that. Um Right.
So, so I guess the
those remarks in this that conversation
gives some context for this work. Um
Uh you can see the title. It has a
number of co-authors and and I'll talk
about them at the end of it. Um
So, I can really
you know, give give you even faces um
to the names. Um all right. So, um let's
let's start. Um so, this this is the
So, so the problems like I suggested
that we that we work on have been sort
of
are sort of inspired by biology, but of
course they hopefully have wider
applications. In this particular case,
we are basically looking at cell
dynamics, right? Cells moving around. Um
something that's known So, so I'm going
to I'm doing this in um
in PDF, so you the cursor will change. I
think you've got a clock right now,
watch right now because there is a movie
running. Anyway.
Um So, so something that's known is that
cell dynamics being being, you know,
populations moving around
obeys
at some level it obeys the physics of
transport problems. So, what we're
seeing here, the the black and white
movie that you're seeing here is a type
of breast cancer cell and as you see the
designation there, this is a breast
cancer cell line. It's it's known to be
very aggressive. It aggressively moves.
Motility refers to movement and
proliferates also. Uh the particular
experiment we're looking at here is what
is called a scratch assay. You see the
schematic here. You take monolayer of
cells, you literally scratch it, right?
You actually introduce a cut in it.
And then you sit back and watch what
happens. And what happens is that
typically these cells will try to close
the wound. It's a wound healing process.
That scratch that we introduced, the
cells will kind of move into it and try
to fill it up.
Uh that's the movie that you're seeing
here. It loops over. So, when it starts
now, you see the black space in between,
that is the scratch. And you see the
cells coming in from both sides. Uh now,
if you just stare at this movie for a
little time and and you say, "Okay, what
are the cells doing?"
Uh something natural to to think is that
they're moving into the scratch. You can
see them moving into the scratch. And
so, one may say that maybe there's some
sort of directed motion. And that
directed motion is suggested by this by
this cartoon here to the left. But then,
if you look at it for a longer time, you
may say, "Hang on, I think there is also
some sort of random walk going on,
right?" Because they're Yeah, they're
moving in one direction, but maybe
they're also moving in in all directions
to some extent, and maybe there's a
superposition of this.
So, the middle cartoon here is meant to
indicate a random walk. So, essentially,
a diffusive type of process.
And finally, if you look at sus Oops,
sorry. If you look at certain of these
cells, they become bright
That one. So, they became bright for an
instant, and then it divided. So, the
cells are doing this also, right? So, a
mother cell gives rise to daughter
cells. Now, if we step back and think
about this as a transport problem, and
you say, "Okay, I'm going to I'm not
going to look at every single cell. I'm
going to define like a population. I can
define a cell density."
You can write out one of these sets of
equations, right? Essentially, it's an
advection-diffusion-reaction equation.
So, the directed motion is advection,
the random walk is diffusion, and this
proliferation of cells, or even if they
die, is a reaction term.
Okay, so that that's that's the sort of
And and so, essentially, this can be you
can subject this to a PDE model.
Uh the movie on the on the bottom is
also from a scratch assay. It's it's a
slightly bigger a sort of
We're stepping back and taking a view of
this.
Uh each of these little
pixels that you see is actually a well.
And if you can see the dimensions here,
right? So, this is 3,000 microns, 3
mm, which is actually pretty big for
cells. So, inside each of those are
cells, and the colors you're seeing are
cell densities. And the same thing's
happening, right? You've introduced a
scratch around the middle
in the vertical
if
And and and the cells are moving. So,
sorry, was there a question?
Okay.
Uh and the cells are moving in, right?
So, this is just a different view of the
same sort of thing. So, one can describe
this thing this this type of motion this
type of dynamics of cells through
through PDEs.
Uh
so, you see the hypothesis up there. Um
what I'm doing here is taking the second
movie and said that well, if you look at
this, there's really not much
interesting going on in the in the
horizontal direction. So, maybe we can
just average over the horizontal
direction or maybe just look at what is
happening at along one particular
vertical line. Okay? So, if you do that,
uh then you can sort of collate these
data in a different way. A way to show
such time-evolving data uh in biology is
what is called a kymograph. It just
means that you plot something, in this
case, Y position along the vertical
axis, and along the horizontal axis, you
put time.
Okay?
Uh and so, okay. So, now let's
understand what what is happening here.
So, the So, So, what we're plotting here
are the cell densities. And if you look
at the early times, you see there's a
large region in the middle where the
cell density is low, the blue colors. Uh
and then as you go along in time, that
middle region fills up as the cells come
closer together, and they get to hotter
colors. Uh So, now Okay. So, and and
then the
the the dotted lines here are just
tracing out contours, right? Contours of
constant uh concentration or constant
density.
It turns out that if you look at the
form of some of these contours, they
have this form Y equals something time
to the power B. That exponent B is
actually of the order of about 0.4.
And so, that suggests oh, it's 0.4.
That's almost 0.5, right? So, is is
diffusion dominating? Right? That's the
sort of question when you look at this
kind of a plot.
So, what we are aiming to do then, what
we aim to do is to say, "Okay, can we
can we actually become more quantitative
about this?"
Uh and this is what we did, right? So,
we looked at cell dynamics. We said,
"Okay, we have this
advection-diffusion-reaction
approach. Let's make some ansatz for all
the parameters." We're saying that
diffusion must be positive, right? Uh
so, we say diffusivity can depend upon
in this fashion, and we we we we allow
for the possibility that everything can
be even positionally dependent, right?
So, we expand it as a polynomial in Y.
Uh Y tilde, which is a scale so that it
goes from What is it? It goes from minus
one minus half to half, right? So, or
something like that, right?
Um
So,
So, we say that diffusivity has to be
positive and all these parameters the
theta's also have to be positive. Uh we
say the direction velocity is zero at
the midpoint because cells are moving up
or down. So, so we write Sorry.
We write this sort of an ansatz for the
advective velocity. We also write the
reaction as a polynomial, right? All as
functions of position.
Um
Also, we make the theta parameters time
dependent. So, we're allowing all these
coefficients to be basically
spatiotemporally varying. Okay? We say,
"Okay, this is my ansatz, right?"
Because I want to see what how these
things are changing. You know, the cell
dynamics may not be constant over time
and space. So, I'll let all these
parameters vary in space and time this
fashion. So, if I write this ansatz
Okay, so we can write this ansatz and we
can say that well, I have the data. Can
I infer what what what's going on? Like,
can I infer what these coefficients are?
That's what we aim to do and we aim to
do this in a in a in a in a sort of
somewhat principled manner. So, we look
for parsimonious model selection. The
method we use There are many methods to
do this. The method we use, we call it
variation system identification. It has
some relation to these other algorithms
called Cindy. Uh sparse identification
of the non-linear dynamics. The
difference is that we do everything in
weak form. Right? So, we take that
transport equation as written here as a
time rate of some cell concentration.
And here chi indicates any operator.
Right? Maybe a diffusion operator, maybe
a reaction operator, advection operator,
and so on. The theta is the coefficient
multiplying it, right? Linear
coefficient. We do everything in weak
form. So, this is what diffusion looks
like. That's what advection looks like.
That's what reaction looks like, and so
on.
Now,
from weak form, of course, you can go to
a finite element description of this in
a matrix vector form.
A lot of
is finite element based, so so that's
what we do. If you write out a finite
element uh
residual for this,
you go through the usual steps, which
may be familiar to many of you here. The
A here is the assembly operator, R is
the residual, which typically
in a finite element setting, we demand
that the residual goes to zero, and we
look for a forward solution.
Here, however, we are saying that look,
we have the data, we know the solution,
we need to determine the coefficients.
We want to determine these coefficients
theta. Theta is now a vector of all the
coefficients multiplying all our
operators.
Uh essentially, this is an optimization
problem. We say that the theta is the
argmin of this residual, right? So, we
we we try to we we are trying to
minimize this residual. Uh it's a
squared residual, so so minimizing it
means sort of the residual going to
zero, and we introduce some
penalty regularization so that the
parameters don't get very big. Now,
there are many parts and then your your
aim is to to find the the argmin. There
are many parsimony promoting approaches.
You can, you know, the one that we use
is called stepwise regression. I won't
get into details about it. I can talk
about it. There are genetic algorithms
and so on. Essentially, it means that
you you choose parameters, you find the
argmin, and you find a way to eliminate
parameters until you come to some
parsimonious set, balancing
representation and parsimony. Okay? This
is this is what the what we do. So, so
we we've written a few papers on this,
and you see a couple of early
references. There is there is more work
that's been done since then by us. Okay.
Uh
we also do this uh sort of parameter
refinement, which is to say that okay,
we use this approach to decide which of
these operators are on or off, right?
You choose them.
And then once you do that, you say,
"Well, I may want to refine the the the
actual parameters of the operators that
are active." And you can do things like
PDE constrained optimization after that,
right? It's fairly standard stuff. Um we
use adjoint-based methods and so forth,
so
it's a standard stuff. Okay. So, what
does this all tell us? Um here's what we
see, okay? I'm going to step you through
these plots.
Uh the first one on the left here, if
you can see my hand cursor, it's the
original data for Y versus time, the sky
micrograph.
Uh we inferred a model and then we ran
the forward model after inferring it. Uh
this is the result we got. It's fairly
similar. There are some differences. One
can look at where the error is. Uh the
error has you know there are some
hotspots where the error is high.
Uh but it's all of the order of um
if I'm not mistaken, this is of the
order of percent, yeah. So, that's
percent error. Okay? So, there are some
hotspots. But what does it tell us,
right? So, we do infer a diffusion and
remember the diffusion of all the
parameters we infer are spatiotemporal.
So, what we're seeing is that versus
position and time, this is what the
diffusivity looks like, right? Mostly
some low value of diffusivity, about 0.2
uh square microns per micron square per
second. per second and there are some
hotspots, right? There are some points
where we picked up bursts of activity.
We look at advection. So, we're looking
at the advection uh velocity
how how much advection there is, but I
I'm presenting it in in terms of the
Peclet number, right? So,
non-dimensionalized with respect to
diffusion. What we're seeing is that
it's mostly zero, mostly this green
region, right? Mostly zero and then
wherever there are bursts of other
activity, we do pick up some bursts of
infection, but mostly zero,
Finally, the reaction we show in terms
of the Damkohler number, it's very
small. The Damkohler number is
essentially of order 10 to the minus
three. So, it's suggesting that
proliferation plays a very small role
here.
Uh there is some directed motion, yes,
but mostly it is diffusion, right? So,
what we saw originally in these data,
where if you look at these contours of
uh constant density, you may say, "Well,
that looks like uh t to the half."
Right? Which would be which would be
classical diffusion. We're getting
something very close to diffusion. We're
actually inferring all these parameters
and seeing that yes diffusion does
dominate. Uh So that suggestion early on
that we're getting T to the maybe 0.4 is
reasonable. But this is again a
principal way of trying to really figure
out what what the cells are doing. So um
we we we've written some papers on this.
There's presently an
an archive preprint which describes our
methods to to look at the you know to
infer these types of reaction advection
diffusion models for wound healing.
Okay?
Um okay. But where is where is this
going? So this is good. You can have
this mean this sort of
mean field approach to looking at cells.
Um sorry. Going the wrong way. Okay.
But then we started looking at other
problems also, right? So we took the
same cell line. Kids this sorry. Being
clumsy here. Sorry about this.
We took the same cell line here
and we now put a chemical gradient upon
them. Okay?
We put a chemical gradient where the
gradient is is sort of attracting the
cells to the to go leftward. It's the
same cell line, but you see here the
cells are a little more sparse. The two
movies that you're seeing are
essentially the same dynamics. The same
exactly the same things going on. On the
left you're seeing only the nuclei. On
the right you're also seeing the cells.
Okay. Now this chemical gradient is is
has been put and the cells are being
attracted to it. This is a
chemoattractant. It's called a CXCL12
here. It's the cell these this type of
cells move in the supposed to move in
the direction of that chemo gradient.
Now if you look at these cells, you will
see that yes many of them are doing
that, right? So you see the cell tracks.
This guy is moving to the left, moving
to the left, and moving to the left, but
not all of them. Like if you look at the
one at the bottom here, right? It
started out and then moved to you see
it's it's moving slightly to the right
and then sort of lose changes its mind,
gets confused, and uh
If you look at the one up here
near the top right here, it is
definitely moving rightward. Uh this guy
up here is a little more uncertain about
what it wants to do,
uh but so on, right? So, the whole point
is and this is long-term data. This is
like 24 hours of data. So, the whole
point is that there is a head lot of
heterogeneity in in cell response.
And while one may think that this is
just stochasticity, there is a strong um
suggestion in cancer in in cancer
biology that the heterogeneity of cell
response is not just stochastic, it's
actually systematic. Uh it's a
significant element of progression in
cancer. And the reason heterogeneity
becomes important is that you may have a
a treatment that treats that that is
targeting a certain type of activity of
the cells. But because of this
heterogeneous behavior, some of the
cells escape. And then there is other
evolutionary things come in. Those cells
are the which can escape to whatever
you're doing to them because they're
doing something different, they're
reacting differently, they're the ones
that survived, they outcompete the
others, they become stronger, they get
more resources, and that is one of the
things that makes
these types of diseases hard to treat.
Okay?
Um okay, so how do we how do we approach
this problem?
Um
So, so first of all, we took this the
cell data and we did a K-means
clustering on them, right? To see, okay,
what type of behavior are we seeing? Uh
we found three clusters to dominate. Uh
so, you can see the binning and all of
that. This is the loss of the K-means
clustering.
Uh three three uh cell clusters. Cluster
zero is is and as you're seeing all the
cell tracks here. Cluster zero are cells
that were moving leftward, right? And
just like the chemoattractant was trying
to do making them was trying to make
them do, right? Wanted to make them It
was put to make them move leftward. But
then there is a serenade contrarian
group of cells which is moving
rightward, right? And I pointed out some
of them.
And then there's a third cluster which
is kind of not quite sure, moving
slightly leftward, but uh maybe a little
more unsure about what they're doing.
Okay? Um
So, we see these three populations.
So,
what what can we do with these three
populations?
We could apply our mean field approaches
to these populations,
but there is a difficulty. There is a
difficulty in that when you are
when if you try to apply a mean field
approach to the whole population, the
fact that there is so much heterogeneity
in them, there is distinct heterogeneity
means that your mean field approach
first of all does not make sense. You
need to have more populations. So, then
you may say, "Okay, I'm going to apply
my approach to each of these
populations, right? Each of these
clusters." You can do that.
I hope you can see this on your screens.
What you should be seeing is that a lot
These are all cells, okay? So, every dot
is a cell.
All the cells are represented. The one
on the left is the cluster that's moving
leftward. So, what we've done is of all
the cells we've put in red the class the
cells that are moving leftward. Okay?
So, you can see if you stare at the the
movie on the left, you will see that
yes, on average the red cells are moving
leftward. You look at this cluster on
the in the middle, you will see that
again on on average the cells that have
been highlighted red in this movie are
the ones moving rightward.
And the third cluster, you can't quite
tell, right? Are they moving leftward,
rightward, and what so on.
Now,
already it turns out that actually the
set these populations, each of these
subpopulations are getting very sparse.
So, mean field approaches are already
beginning to get shaky. But what we did
was we took every cell, we put a
Gaussian on it, you know, kind of
smoothed out got some smoothed out
density. Those are the contours that you
may be able to see just evolving in the
back of your
of these movies. So, we did that to be
able to infer something, right? Though
we know already it's shaky because we
don't we don't even have enough density
here, right? So, totally each of these
groups, for instance,
are of the order of about 300 cells. And
as I recall, the the whole region in
which they are they are moving is of the
order of a few hundreds of microns.
Yeah, maybe even a thousand microns. So,
it turns out that the cell density is
not very hard to do this. But, anyway,
we can go ahead and do this. So, what do
we do?
Uh we do again this this
advection-diffusion model. What we find
is for the three clusters 0, 1, and 2.
Uh we listed the diffusivities. You see
them here. Sorry.
Uh
oops.
Going the wrong way. Okay. Uh we also
inferred the the advection velocities.
So, what we're picking up correctly is
that the this left cluster is dominated
by leftward movement. E1, E2 are just
the basis vectors, right? E1 is in the X
direction, E2 is in the Y direction. So,
the this zero cluster is indeed moving
mainly in the leftward direction with
some amount of right upward motion. The
middle cluster is moving rightward, as
we see that this this E1 component is
rightward. And the third cluster is
moving a little bit leftward, I'm not so
sure. So, we can do this, okay?
But, the point that we realized here was
already that, you know, this is a
problem. These cells are not really
behaving in a mean field manner. We need
to do something different. We maybe need
to really start thinking about them more
as individuals.
Right? So, we need to go to this idea
that these are individual agents. And
so, we're asking, "Okay, can we somehow
go beyond this mean field response and
look at cells as agents?" That's what
we're talking about.
This is where we get into this idea of
Markov processes and so forth, okay?
So, we say, "Okay, let's now look at
this whole thing as each cell
being an agent that is undergoing these
Markov decision processes."
Um
little bit formal a little more formal
here.
Uh so, we look at each cell here as an
agent. Each cell is an agent. It is in
some environment. It could be the body.
Um
the cell has certain states, and we'll
say what these states are.
Uh
from each state this agent the cell
agent can take an action, right? To
change to another state. So, uh
so they follow dynamics
and this is recorded as Markov decision
process.
Um
the state the they have some states.
They're taking some actions. There's
some initial probability of being in a
certain state. So, P is a probability.
There's a transition probability which
says that okay, if you're in some state
S
uh and you take some action A, what is
the probability that you're going to end
up in some state S prime? This is a
transition probability T.
Now, the thing that goes into
treatment here for this particular MDP
Markov decision process is to say that
well, maybe we can find a reward
function, right? So, are the cells
trying to optimize something? Are they
trying to maximize or minimize
something? We say maximize, we call it a
reward. Okay? So, so we say okay, maybe
they get a we can find something that we
can identify as a reward for them to be
in some state and taking some action.
Now, there's more machinery here. You're
you you observe the dynamics here and
and there is this notion of a policy. A
policy is also a it's a probability
distribution. The the policy is the is
the probability of taking a certain
action if you are in a certain state,
right? So, you find yourself in a
certain state, you take an action,
what's the probability of taking that
action? That's that's this the policy.
Uh there's this notion of the optimal
policy. The optimal policy is something
that maximizes a cumulative reward and
the expected value of the cumulative
reward. The cumulative reward is to say
that I don't care only about the reward
I'm going to get right now, but what is
the reward I'm likely to get over time,
right? As I go through very very many
different states. So, this would be the
op- so, that would be the optimal policy
for you to follow, right? So, don't be
greedy, just look for your reward now,
but look think ahead. Okay.
Uh the last thing that we also need is
something called a state action value
function. Uh, it's similar idea. It is
to say that you take the current value
of the reward you get plus what is what
do you expect for your future, right?
So, kind of save for the future and that
value is is another important idea here.
Okay.
The whole and and and like I said
earlier, I'll I'll just reiterate the
reward is the motivation like driving
agent behavior saying right now what
you're going to get. Uh, the policy and
transition are probability functions
which together describe these dynamics,
okay? Right? So, some amount of
formalism here. We'll we'll be using
this.
Um, okay.
Now, when one looks at MDP this little
more here, this is where learning comes
in, right? So, you say, "Okay, if I see
a certain if I if I if I if I have
trajectories, right?" I have a Markov
decision process uh, where I have these
agents cells occupying certain states.
They can take certain actions. There's
an initial probability of the
distribution. Maybe I have a transition
function. Know how they're going to
change between one state given a state
and action, what what is the probability
they'll be in another state.
And there's some idea of reward.
Now, reinforcement learning algorithms
take all of this information and try to
find the optimal policy that the cells
are following. There's a big um,
diagram here. It basically says that you
have certain trajectories. You have some
initial probability. The trajectories go
from zero to
final time T. They're also taking
actions from the between um, initial
time and a final time.
Uh, and then there's this notion of
transition and reward and all of this is
is used to determine the policy. This is
standard reinforcement learning where
the central uh, uh, quantity you're
trying to get is this policy and this is
a probability distribution function. Uh,
you also want the value but the policy
is really central. Uh, it tells you in a
state, what is the probability that you
will take a certain action. Okay.
But here, uh what we observe is that,
okay, for for reinforcement learning,
you need to know
the transition.
You need to know what the reward is.
Here, we don't know this for cells. So,
we need to do something else. We need to
also figure out what the reward is. And
actually, what we need to have some
insight to the transition, also. What
this means is and we also want to figure
out the policy. So, really, we're
solving an inverse problem.
This brings us to inverse reinforcement
learning.
Now, conventional inverse reinforcement
learning, and we use the acronym IRL, it
says, given trajectories and a
transition function, you try to infer
the reward, right? So, I won't go
through all these details here. I'll
just go to the diagram. Um again, you're
given trajectories, those are the data,
right? They start out with some initial
probability of being sent some state.
And essentially, with this inverse
inverse reinforcement learning, you can
go from trajectories directly to
transitions, or you may have some
knowledge about what the transitions
are.
Traditional
inverse reinforcement learning
algorithms just look at the trajectories
and empirically say, "Okay, I can see
how the these agents are doing all these
things. I can see how these cells are
changing states. I can simply
empirically uh just by counting figure
out a transition probability. Okay,
that's an empirical one.
Um
the problem with doing this is that
you're going it's it's poor at
extrapolation because you're just going
with the data that you have. You're just
seeing the system that you have.
Extrapolation is going to be bad, as we
know all these these processes, right?
All these sort of data-driven processes.
So, the question is, can we introduce
some mechanistic behavior, or can we
introduce some physics to this, right?
Can we have a more principled way of
coming up with these transitions?
Once we have that,
we can think about IRL algorithms which
also infer the reward and the policy,
right? So, and all remember, all of this
we're going to bring to bear upon cells.
How do we do this?
We took two approaches. I'll go through
the first approach rather quickly
because it's not Well, you know, it was
our first shot at it.
Uh remember we said that the cells can
be in three clusters.
At the outset we said, "Okay, let's look
at the cell initially right at the
outset choosing to belong to one of
these clusters, right? Choosing to say
that I want to be the one of these guys
moving left or right or I'm not so
sure."
That we said initially is an action. So,
we had effectively a discrete action
space where the cell could get one of
three choices and it could make had to
make them at the beginning. Okay.
Um
Um all right. So, so with that with that
idea,
uh the approach we took to to to solving
this this inverse problem inverse
reinforcement learning problem is one
where we said, "Okay, we want to we we
use algorithms which would maximize the
total reward the cumulative reward over
all times
while also accounting for the
possibility that the also concurrently
saying that look, I don't know what the
future holds so I'm going to maximize
the uncertainty of my prediction."
Uh in particular there's a quantity
called causal entropy. These type of IRL
algorithms were described
more than 10 years ago. That's called
maximizing causal entropy, right? So,
that's what these algorithms do.
Um
But still remember
uh what about the transition
probability, right? It needs a
transition probability function.
So, this is where we said, "Oh, wait. I
know how to If I look at these data, I
can go back to my inference methods, my
my system identification methods and
maybe from there I can get something."
What can I get here?
Let's look at the right part of the
slide here.
It turns out that the cell
concentrations when rescaled can be
actually regarded as a probability
distribution density function, right?
You look at the concentration of cells
somewhere you can turn that into
probability density function. And then
we we become we we have available to us
the Fokker-Planck equation, right? Which
essentially continuing to use C here,
but think about C as a probability
distribution density function. Okay? So,
in the Fokker-Planck equation, psi here
is a potential.
Um and essentially you're looking at
at the gradient of a potential and you
have this divergence coming from the
gradient of a potential and another
diffusion term.
Uh of course the gradient of a potential
if you just stick in a constant vector
for it gives you back advection. Okay?
But this form is is more general one,
which is the Fokker-Planck equation. Uh
there's been a lot lot of work on it and
and a few seminal papers coming out from
these
from Jordan, Kinderlehrer, Lehrer, and
Otto.
Uh in '98, they showed that this form,
the Fokker-Planck equation, is a
Wasserstein gradient flow of the entropy
regularized energy.
What that means essentially is that the
system is minimizing this total free
energy consisting of a potential. Now,
we have a potential for the cells. It is
a potential coming from that
chemoattractant, right? Which is a
chemical gradient there. And then
there's an entropy term. Now,
we realized then that hang on, we are
minimizing this quantity that's
equivalent to maximizing the negative of
this quantity.
We said, "Can we connect this
maximization of the negative potential
with the fact that we are maximizing a
total reward in these in these
reinforcement learning on these MDP
processes?"
So, as a sort of conjecture, we said,
"Okay, maybe I can determine the
potential for these three cell types,
these three populations, and use that to
write my reward function." Right?
Because I need to have I needed to have
some sense of what this reward function
could be. I still need to determine the
coefficients, but I still could use this
this
potential for each of these three
if I can identify a potential for each
of these three cell groups I could say
okay I can expand my reward in those
cells. We could do that and then we go
ahead and do our inference method here
the system identification that was I
showed you earlier.
For the same cell group I already I
think I showed you these values that we
got earlier but now we're reinterpreting
them as a potential. So psi for the
three groups is shown here.
S1 S2 okay S1 S2
are basically positions you can think
about them as the X and Y coordinates.
So the state here we're seeing as
position.
So this is the potential for the for the
first group the potential for the second
group and the potential for the third
group. Now because we're writing we
identified Fokker-Planck equations for
each of them we also get from the
Fokker-Planck equation the Fokker-Planck
equation can be collect connected to a
discrete probabilistic um
form also that gives us a transition
probability which is in this form. If
you look at this carefully you may
recognize actually the fundamental
solution of the heat equation also
sitting in side of it like it has
relations to others.
That allows us to write out the reward
function in this fashion right? So for
each cell cell group I have determined
what the potential is psi zero psi one
and psi two for the three groups and
then I have to determine these three
quantities my thetas. If I can infer all
of that I have a reward. Okay?
And we described this approach in in a
in a paper.
Okay. So what do we find? Um
This part is a little abstract I'm going
to go over it quickly but okay we find
this is what the reward looks like for
the cell groups.
This is this is position
X direction Y direction.
For all three cell groups where the the
reward is is warmer that's where they
should be going right? So it's so it's
the method realizes that's where they
should be going.
But interestingly it finds that even
this middle group this is the group of
cells which are moving rightward. It
they know they know the reward is is to
the left but for some reason they're
moving rightward so the so the method
kind of the IRL algorithm we have here
recognizes that these cells are moving
against the imposed gradient.
That's this group here.
How good is our is our inference here
with our with IRL?
We are finding These are the policies,
right? So, the policies are what is the
probability of you taking a certain
action when you're in a given state.
What it is saying is that for for group
one, if they are at toward the left end,
the their their their probability of
moving leftward is higher. Uh for the
group in the middle, if
they this is the group that's moving
rightward, it does recognize that you
already are rightward.
That that's what makes you go in the
direction that you're going. And this is
the actual data point, right? So, we
find policies that kind of connect up
well with what the cells are really
doing.
However, this treatment was not very
satisfactory. It was not satisfactory
mainly because
we were already sort of
forcing the cells to choose what their
actions were. The cells had to decide at
the beginning whether they wanted to be
group one moving left, group two moving
right, or group three not quite sure.
And then even what we found was really
just reflecting what we'd chosen. So,
not a very suitable approach. So, we
said, "Okay, we really have to go away
from this idea of pre-deciding that you
have only three actions to choose from,
making action an an a discrete space,
and like forcing you to be fixed there."
So,
we had to describe a different approach.
We had to come up with a different
approach which would allow the cells to
choose from continuous actions and also
on the fly
decide to take different actions from
the ones they've taken in the past,
right? To sort of change their minds.
What this meant formally was that we had
to put state and action into a
continuous space, a single continuous
state-action space. We call this X. Now,
X refers to this this this joint space
of states and actions.
Turns out that even this type of
behavior can be modeled by a
multi-variable Fokker-Planck equation
for the time evolution of the
probability density which now depends on
X where X however is your state and
occupation uh state and action.
Uh the the Fokker-Planck equation looks
the same except that now all of these
X's instead of being only position are
like you know a state and action. Okay?
Uh
if you and and again the joint
probability transition function is also
as before as when you can solve the
Fokker-Planck equation you can get it as
a function of the of the potential that
you may infer for this multi-variate
Fokker-Planck equation. Okay.
Looking at the Fokker-Planck equation
and the MDP we recognize that there is
an isomorphism in structure between the
Fokker-Planck equation and and these
MDPs.
Specifically, we observe that the
potential function in the Fokker-Planck
equation
is equivalent to this other quantity
that I introduced it's called the
state-action value function.
Just tell you again what it is. It is
what the the the reward that you have
presently plus the reward that you
expect to get over all the possible
trajectories you may take in the future.
Okay? We found this kind of isomorphism
between them structurally they had they
seem to be playing exactly the same
role. Why?
In the Fokker-Planck equation the
potential drives the lumped state
evolution in in in the in the
Fokker-Planck dynamics. It's the
potential which is the driving. In MDPs
it is again the state-action value
function that sort of guides the agent's
actions and therefore states.
We found that we made this
identification a bunch of other things
flow. Also I apologize if it looks looks
heavy but I'll tell you what what what
each case is doing.
From Fokker-Planck dynamics it turns out
that a steady state distribution
you can show it that it is the minimizer
of the free energy. Yeah, and this is a
result that one can derive from
Fokker-Planck. So, it says that this
this distribution is the minimizer of
the energy and it has this particular
form, right? This comes from the
Fokker-Planck equation.
Now, this depends upon states and
actions. One can marginalize this over
the actions by just doing this
integration over action space. So, now
you have the steady state marginal
distribution only in terms of states.
The conditional distribution then of an
action is given by the ratio of what you
have in this first line and the second
line, right? It's this. Takes on this
form.
This This structure here has the same
form as the Boltzmann policy from the
rein- from reinforcement learning. Okay?
And why There's a further connection
here. It says this quantity here from
Fokker-Planck says, "What is the
probability of you having taken an
action from a given state at steady
state?"
This tells you again policy, right? What
is the probability of taking an action
from a given state, right? So, they're
even conceptually they are the same
thing and we observe that their
structure is also very
It is actually identical. So, we So,
this is kind of evidence sort of
supporting our conjecture. Still a
conjecture, it's not not a theorem,
okay?
Um
So, we have this connection. Um
Furthermore, we can get a joint
transition function from the
Fokker-Planck, okay? With this
transition function,
one can
one can and and the state value action
function, which is equal to the policy
which is equal to the potential from
Fokker-Planck. One can
obtain the reward through a
the equation called the inverse Bellman
equation in in MDPs.
Uh we observe the theorem, which is
basically saying that the there is a
one-to-one
that there's a bijective map between a
value function and the reward. okay?
That's just a theorem.
It's not important. Just says that if
you have a value function, you can get a
reward from it. Okay.
What do we do with this? So,
here's our approach. We say, "Okay, you
infer a Fokker-Planck equation, okay,
given these data."
Uh you need to parameterize the
potential function. We parameterize it
in terms of Hermite polynomials.
We do our system identification for
Fokker-Planck. Okay.
Uh we get some diffusivity and we get
some other parameters, right? So, we we
do this.
With that, since we know the potential
function from Fokker-Planck,
we observe
um that the potential function
uh once once we have the potential
function,
uh that potential function is the same
as the state-action value function for
for the Markov decision process.
That gives us the Boltzmann policy for
the Markov process by by by this
observation that we made from our
conjecture.
We get a joint transition probability
function for you for this cell that is
as is in state S, takes action A to go
to state S' with action A'.
Um
we can also marginalize the transition
probability uh function to get now the
probability of just being in a certain
state given a state and action.
Finally, we can use this thing called
the inverse Bellman equation to come up
with the reward. So, the whole idea is
that if you can look at the cells, come
up with the Fokker-Planck equation, that
actually gives us a lot of information
for the for to solve this MDP, which
defines the cells' evolutions as agents.
Okay. And I know I'm running out of time
here, so I'll just show you some some
some results we got with this. We first
set up a synthetic problem.
Um the detail details of the synthetic
problem are not how we set it up is not
important. These are not cells, right?
We just created some data, let the
system evolve, and and uh and and then
applied our our combined approach. So,
now we have an approach if you recognize
where we can solve a Fokker-Planck
equation and use it to drive this
inverse reinforcement learning. So, we
call this Fokker-Planck inverse
reinforcement learning. This is the
approach we apply to our data. Um on the
left here we see the ground truth uh
value function. Uh
the the X and Y axis here are states.
Okay, so these are positions in this
case.
Uh and we also had the action, right?
This is a joint space. So, within each
of these squares, if you see each of
these squares is also colored. So, so
the colors within the squares give you
the actions, right? So, because it's
actually a four-dimensional space. So, I
had to have some way of showing this.
So, I'm showing you 2D and inside each
of these squares for a given values of
states, uh we're showing you the
actions. So, this is our way of showing
this four four four four-dimensional
space.
This is again showing the reward.
Uh this just shows for us synthetic data
how the probability density is evolving.
It starts at time t = 0, goes as far as
time t = 19. So, so these states are
evolving uh towards these these two
hotspots here, right? So, as the thing
proceeds. We applied our Fokker-Planck
inverse reinforcement learning to this.
We generate the trajectories, we solve
the Fokker-Planck equation for it, and
then sort of try to recover what we'd
originally posed as ground truth. And
this is what we got, right? Up here you
see the ground truth reward. Uh this is
the inferred reward below. Not a bad
match, sorry.
Uh this is the ground truth value
function. This is the inferred value
function from our Fokker-Planck inverse
reinforcement learning.
Uh this is the a a plot showing the KL
divergence, which is KL divergent
between the data and the inferred
probability distributions, right? Um
also declining. As it declines, it means
those two distributions are coming
closer together.
And this just shows the sort of L2 error
of the of the four state and action.
As we as we refine the mesh, as we went
to more and more
states,
the states are defined over the same
space, but as we we went to more and
more finer grid, we're seeing that the
error goes up. So, this is a synthetic
problem. Of course, we want to apply it
to this problem, right? It's cancer cell
dynamics. So, same thing. Now, I'm
coming back to those cells.
In addition to moving around, when I
showed you many movies of the cells
moving around, these cells are also
expressing quantities, right? They're
expressing many
kinases and proteins and so on.
Two in particular that we that our
biologists collaborators focused on
AKT and ERK.
We don't need to get into what exactly
they are, but they're they're what are
called kinase transfer kinase transport
kinase transport reporters.
Both these quantities these proteins AKT
and ERK or
they're kinases are related to motion in
various ways, right? There's a
correlation between them.
So, this again is a kymograph seeing
about thousands of about no of the order
of about yeah about order of about a
thousand cells going up here. Each of
these traces shows how the cells are
expressing AKT over time. So, in each of
these plots, the horizontal axis from
here to here is time, and these are
different cells. So, that is their AKT
expression, this is the ERK expression,
this is the speed, and this is their
direction speed, right? So, this is what
they are our biologists are observing.
With these data, we said, "Okay, we will
apply it to our Fokker-Planck inverse
reinforcement learning."
Now, we have to define what states are.
Unlike earlier, when we were using
positions as states, we decided here to
use velocities. There's a lot of detail
about why we came up with velocities.
So, the states are the velocities of
these cells.
The actions now, we've made a difference
here, right? We said the actions instead
of initially what we said was that this
actions were you had to choose which
group you wanted to belong in. Now,
we're saying the actions are at
continuous space, right? And they're
just what is your expression level of
these two kinases of ERK and AKT.
Those are our actions. So, with our
Fokker-Planck inverse reinforcement
learning, we wanted to see is okay, is
there is there a relation between these
velocities and and and the expression of
these kinases.
So, we applied our approach, determined
the Fokker-Planck equation for these
quantities, used that to solve the IRL
problem.
This is what we see. Again, very
abstract plots, not at all clear what's
going on here, but let me tell you.
Uh this is a plot of the reward. So, the
colors, wherever it's hotter, is where
you get a bigger reward, right? The
cells are getting a higher reward here.
The axes X and Y are states. So, uh they
show velocities. So,
everything is normalized, right? So, in
the middle you have a zero velocity, you
have a positive velocity to the right at
at this end here,
uh
velocity to the left here,
uh up and down along the Y axis, okay?
So, if you look at this, we see
immediately, okay, you get more reward
if you're moving leftward and toward the
top, right? So, this is again in the
direction of of of of where we know the
reward is, right? Because the gradient
was to the left. The cells moving to the
left indeed get a higher reward. We're
seeing that.
But here's the other interesting thing.
Hopefully, you can see these tiny
squares here. Inside each of those
squares, each square now is a particular
value of X and Y velocity, right? So,
let's let look let's look at one of
these squares.
Inside that square, hopefully, you can
see smaller squares if you're able to
stare at your screen.
Those smaller squares give us the
expression level of these two kinases at
that combination of velocities. So, we
look at where the rewards are high and
we see, "Okay, the highest reward within
any of these squares is where we get the
yellowest value."
But, that is obtained where if you look
at the square, you will see that the the
on the horizontal axis within the
square, you get a higher reward if
you're slightly to the left and uh along
this along the vertical axis of the
square, if you're higher up.
So, what that translates to in terms of
these two kinases we're looking at is
low values of AKT. AKT is plotted along
the horizontal axis in each square, and
you got to be to the left in each
square, so that's low AKT. And you need
to be to the toward the top in each
square, that's high ERK. This is what
we're This is what our method inferred.
This shows the policy, and I'm not going
to get into it too too much. Let's just
look at the reward.
So, we went to our biologist friends and
told them this, and then they realized
that actually this this this Okay. So,
they said, "Actually, this is what we've
been doing to these cells." The same
cells they've applied a number of
different um
interventions to them, right? So, they
they've been doing a lot of chemical
interventions to them. This is the
control, no chemicals applied. Bunch of
different chemicals. This is an
interesting one. They had applied
trametinib. This is a is is is is a is a
chemical that actually
knocks down the action of ERK, which is
one of these kinases. So, when ERK is
knocked down, the velocities become very
small, right? Compared to the control.
These are trajectories, right? So, as
you can see, the trajectories are much
much more limited, they're not moving
that much.
Okay?
The one on the right is uh elbasil which
is another chemical which actually
knocks down the action of AKT, the other
kinase.
Interestingly, when they knocked down
the action of AKT, the trajectories are
a little bigger than the control, right?
If you look at this, on average they're
a little bigger. They did a more careful
analysis of this and indeed they found
that when they when they when they
knocked this down they get a slightly
greater velocity when they put down AKT.
So essentially what we're finding is
that when we from from our prediction
which said that AKT should be low and
ERK should be high, that is exactly what
they realized after the fact. This was
blind to us. We reported this to them
and then they came up with this this the
fact that they had run these controls
and found these found these results.
Um
So
Uh we you know there's this idea that
theory only takes you so far. I expanded
that to what Oppenheimer is supposed to
have said. He said, "Well, they won't
fear it until they understand it. They
won't understand it until they used it."
So we showed it to biologists and said,
"Well, this is what it this this is how
all these methods these AI methods can
be can be useful actually showing
something." Um
That's it really. This is just details
about the algorithms. So to summarize,
um
you can use mean field approaches for to
describe cell dynamics breaks down.
We're interested in heterogeneity
uh and we've gone to this
approach where we can connect
Fokker-Planck
with an inverse reinforcement learning.
There is this conjecture that there is a
connection between them
something that we're still working on
trying to sort of beef it up but we're
definitely seeing a lot of evidence that
is suggest that this may make sense.
Um there's a preprint out and um
you know there there are many greater
opportunities in looking at optimal
transportation theory. The Fokker-Planck
equation as many of you may know very
well is is is one is is is part of the
of of optimal
transportation theory.
Uh our work has been supported by KECK
and these are all the people. So
everybody in the top line is either grad
students or postdocs who have been doing
all the work.
Chengyang Wang and Siddhartha Sibasish
him Zena Wang did a lot of this work.
Patrick Cannon and also C. Kenneth Cole
is the post doc who did a lot of the
experimental stuff. All my colleagues
are the Lukers or biologists.
Nicola Banovic and Shin Juan are data
scientists.
Shin Juan Juan Manito knows from was it
Sandia Labs and yeah, that's that's
where I should end here. I didn't
go too too far.
That awesome. Thank you so much. Have
wonderful wonderful talk.
Pretty pretty informal.
I was able to follow.
Not all of them. Not all of them but the
We are also still learning. I got to
confess. We are learning this also.
On both sides even the
even the even the
IRL stuff. We are learning.
Great. Great. Great. Okay. Thank you so
much.
Let's have a Q&A session. Um
if you have any question, please unmute
yourself and ask your questions. You are
welcome to do so now because
it's a Q&A.
Um
I I can start. Um
You you basically show, you know, in
gradually
and procedural way. I mean, you show
like, you know, let's divide it three
groups and then you know,
and conquer separately and then combine
them later and that approach and later
on
you know, using that conjecture you have
between the isomorphism and the focal
point and um you know, Markov chain
process. Um you you get rid of those,
you know, the divide dividing process
and just
monolithically solve it.
Is there a way of, you know,
comparing those two methods and find out
the performance between those two and
considering
Right. So so the turns out that the
descriptions are so different that they
almost become apples and oranges because
the first approach yeah because with the
first approach the way we are fixing
actions the actions are no longer
available for us to um
evaluate. Like we fix them. Furthermore,
we're even saying that the cells have to
decide at the very beginning what they
want to be so they cannot switch it on.
Yeah.
So we can we of course we could compare
we could compare you know we could look
at maybe the L2 error in in in you know
in what
in our predictions, right?
Right. Though in the second case our
space is bigger so maybe we take the
subspace of just of
Yeah, maybe just look at the subspace of
velocities and compare with what
velocities you were getting in the other
case um
that's that's a possibility. Even that
becomes difficult because in the first
case the velocities were just three
velocities, right? Each for each So so
so the comparison is a little difficult
in that sense.
Um
we could look at the reward I guess. I
guess we could That that is something we
could do, right?
We did not do that so we could we would
need to set up a synthetic problem
approach in the two different ways
and problem approach in the two
different ways
and
try to come up with something.
The in terms of computational cost I
guess the the latter one is more
demanding computational
Yeah, much much much more demanding
computational.
The first one.
Yeah, the first one is very it's much
much much quicker. The second one is
more demanding because we are solving in
a four-dimensional space so it it scales
as we define
our
our our description itself is 4D so it
so it scale it it explodes pretty
quickly. Right.
But but but on GPUs it's it's and then
the IRL also for the same reason. But
but on GPUs it's
we can get some benefit. We are sort of
we went up to about a 20 by 20 grid for
all the all forces uh the
space all four dimensions
that was sort of on the edge of what we
could get on CPUs with even the
even with I think of the order of uh
tens of nodes maybe 20 nodes on expanse
we were getting
it was still taking a few hours for each
case.
So so yeah but but you yeah there's some
accelerator but it's it's expensive yes.
I see.
Well it's a it's a it's a fascinating
and and I think the new idea you're
exploring right right now.
Exactly.
Hopefully it will take you to the really
groundbreaking
Yeah yeah well well hopefully yeah
hopefully we'll see that that's it's
nice because there's some theory and
there are some results some applications
also.
Right right.
Uh if you don't mind like going to slide
seven uh really beginning of the of your
talk I saw that inferred um the results
is there's a some stripes I can almost
see the some spherical stripes.
Yeah exactly.
Is is it
is it uh normal is it supposed to
No I think I think that's just a
function of what
time steps we were using for the um
I suspect that in this case the time
steps we were using for the inference
were uh
were larger than what we were using.
I see.
Yeah and then then we had from the data
in this particular case.
I see I guess that's
Exactly.
some numerical
numerical
Yeah but it's it's it's it's a that's a
numerical artifact.
I see. Um
and then you talked about the
variational the system identification
Yes.
kind of like the weak form of the Cindy
Mhm.
Yeah.
Very interesting. You know the the
groups in Colorado at Boulder they have
some of the weak Cindy
Yeah yeah yeah the weak Cindy so they
yes so so they they followed our they
came up a just after our papers had
appeared they got in touch with us and
and and they were describing these
methods. Yeah, we are we are we are
aware of those methods. We we have not
um
Yeah, we haven't pursued the system
identification itself
much more in the good in in that
direction. We've gone off in in in in
other directions in terms of applying it
to all bunch of other problems and just
trying to come up with better ways to do
this. We're also looking at some genetic
We've looked a little bit at genetic
algorithms to to sort of make the
choices.
Yeah.
It turns out that this problem of of of
choosing um
these these operators or or which ones
to turn on and off it can become
combinatorially very large quickly
because because it's actually if you
look at the graph of all possible models
it can get very very big.
Um so one possibility we're looking
there there is to see whether these
methods themselves because of their
combinatorial growth uh
become become interesting for quantum
computing.
Whether whether this sort of approach is
uh
Mhm.
is because it yeah, if you want to truly
explore all possible models we we follow
Oh, I see. I see.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. If you truly yeah, if
you want to truly explore all models
that that becomes a very very very big
very big problem.
Right, right, right.
So yeah, that's the direction we're
going. But but sorry, you may have a had
a question on weak sending.
Oh, yeah. I mean I'm I'm as a matter of
fact I I do work with them.
Oh, I see. I see.
And then um you know, one of the
the key features they always highlight
is like when whenever there's a noise in
in the data
the weak form is it's so much so much
more robust than you know, strong form
of strong form of the Cindy.
That's right.
And I I I I guess you you you answer my
um
you know, expected questions, you know,
by saying that you you kind of went to
different route. Um you didn't go
into the route of identification realm
of smart
Right. No, we we have not followed up
the questions of um
Yeah, what is you know, what is the what
is how do you characterize the amount of
noise that these things uh
that that these weak approaches would
would uh
would still work well with we haven't
gone down
I see. I see. I see.
I see. I see.
All right. I
I guess I'm asking too much too many
questions. Um I have to give a chance to
audiences to ask question. Uh
If you have um any question, um please
unmute yourself and ask.
All right. Um
End of the presentation.
One last question for me.
Yes, please.
I I was saving one
Um
If you go to slide four, like
like previous previous slide, um you are
kind of modeling the diffusion terms and
uh advection
velocity terms with a some sort of
polynomials and
Uh why up to only fourth order? Um you
could go to sixth order.
You could just keep going, but uh the
point
which Yeah, which is Well, that that's
the that's the thing with all these
these um
these sparse regression approaches,
right? I mean, ultimately they're
regression approaches, so we always
start out with the library. And at some
point you could uh you you know, you end
you you put an end to the li- how far
you're going out with the library.
Right. Right. Right.
Yeah, we could go on.
I I I guess you you haven't explored
those things.
Uh
Yeah, we we Yeah, we haven't Yeah, we
haven't gone that far. I mean, in this
case we were we were quite driven by um
I wanted to come up with something that
was looks you know, explaining the
question the the the phenomenon well
enough and uh
and then proceed on to other things
here. We Yeah, we could have we could
have gone on with
Yeah.
All right.
Okay, great. Thanks so much.
Thank you so much for the wonderful talk
and let's let's thank our speaker today.
Yes, if I may Thank thank you all very
very much. If I may have your attention
uh hold you for just a second. So, I'm
changing coordinates and uh beginning of
January I'll be moving to um
USC.
Oh, you are? Oh, it's closer to us now.
Yeah, yeah, much closer, right? Just
down the coast. And one of the really
interesting things at USC is that there
is a big um
initiative in computing in advanced
computing.
Uh it's called um So, if you ever would
have a chance, just look at
computing.usc.edu.
Yeah.
There is lots of hiring is going to be
going on here at senior and intermediate
levels um
in computational science of the kind we
do we all do.
So, uh
Um
keep keep keep an eye open for it.
I guess you're you're you're kind of
leading that, you know,
Well,
I'll I'll
I'll have a I'll have a role.
There are there are there are
aspects of it, yeah.
I'm sure you're going to play an
important role there. Um
Well, thank you for letting us know.
It's it's exciting, yes. Yeah. Okay.
Well, thank you for the wonderful talk.
Yeah.
Thank you. Thanks Thanks for the
invitation. Thanks, everybody.
Thank you.
Yep.
Uh
Krishna?
Yeah.
Um